The American roach has 154 olfactory receptors for smell,...
...and 544 gustatory receptors for taste,...
...more than any other insect on the planet.
As a result, these cockroaches are not picky eaters.
Sure, they like cheese, meat and sugar like the rest of us,...
...but they'll also go for things like cardboard, book bindings,...
...human toenails, rotting meat, blood, excrement, and even each other.
It sounds gross,...
...but this diverse diet makes it easy to find a meal just about anywhere,...
...even if it's poisonous to most animals.
This roach has a bunch of genes called Cytochrome P450s,...
...which help it withstand poisonous chemicals, like peppermint.
These genes code for detoxification enzymes, which keep the insect safe.
On top of that, this roach has a super-strong immune system...
...that seeks out and kills harmful microbes and fungi,...
...making the most unsanitary environment...
...look like a five-star hotel to the American cockroach.